my people my people the new government
has now free education you got to see
this Kimani okay I heard on the radio
the man's children they said everybody
someone as old as you want to
participate want to learn to read I'm
making an executive decision
[Music]
grumbling no man like him does not
belong in a classroom full of children
he fought the British
it was imprisoned in became
[Music]
if we let Muruga in how can we refuse
others why are you risking anything
because of this old man I know it's me
to fight for my rule gets why we go home
and rest in peace
I'm not gay
to get them or to behave so Webb told
them if they didn't behave I'll clobber
them with my stick
planet I must read it for my
you must love education
because of American freedom freedom we
have to learn from her past we must not
forget we must be better
3484 years gone back to school old are
you 54 55 we are good luck
[Music]
you